>>> IN OUROLITICS LEAD,
DEMOCRATS HEADED INTO THE
NOVEMBER MIDTERM ELECTIONS WITH
SOME ELEORAL OPTIMISM THAT
THEY HAVE NOT LT IN MONTHS
BROUGHT ABOUT BY FALLING GAS
PRICES, REACTION TO THE DECISION
OVERTURNING ROE V. WADE AND A
STRING OF LEGISLATIVE
ACHIEVEMENTS WHICH HAVE SEEN
DEMOCRATIC POLL NUMBERS RISE,
BUT A NEW ANALYSIS IN "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" COULD PROVIDE CAUSE
FOR CONCERN.
QUOTE, THAT WARNING SIGN IS
FLASHING AGAIN.
DEMOCRATIC SENATE CANDIDATES ARE
OUTRUNNING EXPECTATIONS IN THE
SAME PLACES WHERE THE POLLS
OVERESTIMATED MR. BIDEN IN 2020
AND MRS. CLINTON IN 2016 AND
RAISES THE POSSIBILITY THAT THE
APPARENT DEMOCRATIC STRENGTH IN
WISCONSIN AND ELSEWHERE IS A
MIRAGE, AN ARTIFACT OF
PERSISTENT BIASES IN SURVEY
RESEARCH.
LAURA, LET ME START WITH YOU.
HOW DO YOU THINK DEMOCRATS
SHOULD TAKE THIS "NEW YORK
TIMES" ANALYSIS?
>> I THINK THAT COMPARED TO, YOU
KNOW, TEN YEARS AGO OR SO
DEMOCRATS ARE FAR MORE SKEPTICAL
WHEN THEY SEE THAT THEY'RE WAY
AHEAD IN POLLING.
THE DEMOCRATS THAT I TALK TO SAY
THAT THEY DON'T BY ANY MEANS
THINK THE SENATE IS IN THE BAG.
THEY JUST THINK THAT IT'S A MUCH
BETTER LANDSCAPE THAN IT WAS,
SAY, FIVE, SIX MONTHS AGO,
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT THEY
SEE THE LANDSCAPE ON THE GROUND
CHANGING DRAMATICALLY AFTER THE
DOBBS DECISION AND, OF COURSE,
VOTER REGISTRATION IS A BIG
ASPECT OF THAT BUT A LOT OF THEM
EXPECT THE RACES TO BE REALLY
TIGHT AND, YOU KNOW, I SEE THAT
TOO.
I MEAN JUST BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT THE SENATE, DEMOCRATS HAVE
TO HOLD ON TO ALL THE SEATS THAT
THEY CURRENTLY HOLD AND THEN
PLUS GAIN TWO OTHERS AND THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT FEELING MORE
OPTIMISTIC IN NORTH CAROLINA AND
OHIO BUT THOSE WILL BE LIFTS FOR
THEM.
>> SCOTT, REPUBLICANS SEEM TO
WIN JUST TWO OF THE MOST
COMPETITIVE RACES WHICH ARE IN
PENNSYLVANIA, GEORGIA, NEVADA
AND ARIZONA AS OF RIGHT NOW.
CURRENT POLLING HAS DEMOCRATS UP
IN ALL OF THOSE RACES.
ARE REPUBLICANS COUNTING ON
POLLING OVERESTIMATING
DEMOCRATIC SUPPORT AS SOME OF
THESE POLLS HAVE IN THE PAST?
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW THEY'RE
COUNTING ON IT BUT THERE IS A
MEMORY THAT THE SENATE POLLING
REALLY GOING BACK TO 2014 THAT
WE'RE ALL PRIVY TO IS ABSOLUTE
GARBAGE AND MOST HAVE
OVERESTIMATED DEMOCRATS.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE IT TRUE AND
YOU WON'T KNOW UNTIL AFTER THE
ELECTION SO YOU CAN'T COUNT ON
IT BUT IN THE BACK OF EVERYONE'S
MINDS.
REPUBLICANS ARE FEELING REALLY
GOOD ABOUT GEORGIA, REALLY GOOD
ABOUT NEVADA, IF DEMOCRATS ARE
BANKING ON NORTH CAROLINA AND
OHIO, I MEAN, SO I THINK THE
CONDITIONS AND THE LANDSCAPE
EXIST FOR REPUBLICANS BUT THERE
ARE A LOT OF CLEAR EYES ABOUT
SOME CHANGES IN THE POLLING,
SOME CHANGES IN THE ENTHUSIASM
NUMBERS.
AND ALSO THE FACT THAT THESE ARE
PURPLE STATES.
THEY WERE INCREDIBLY CLOSE.
>> ABSOLUTELY AND DEMOCRATS ARE
LEANING INTO THE MESSAGING ON
PROTECTING ABORTION ACCESS IN
THE WAKE OF THE DOBBS DECISION.
AND I WANT YOU TO TAKE A LISTEN
TO THE DEMOCRATIC SENATE
CANDIDATE, LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
OF PENNSYLVANIA JOHN FETTERMAN
TALKING BEFORE VOTERS YESTERDAY.
>> WOMEN ARE THE REASON WE CAN
WIN.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN, WOMEN ARE
THE REASON WE WIN.
DON'T PISS WOMEN OFF.
>> DO YOU THINK THIS WILL BE A
DECISIVE FORCE IN SOME OF THESE
RACES?
>> YOU KNOW, LISTEN, I THINK
IT'S GOING TO CERTAINLY BE A
MOTIVATING FORCE FOR SO MANY
VOTERS OUT THERE, PARTICULARLY
SUBURBAN WOMEN, SUBURBAN WHITE
WOMEN IN PARTICULAR AND THAT'S A
GROUP OF WOMEN THAT REPUBLICANS
HAVE FRANKLY STRUGGLED WITH.
YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE THINGS I
THINK WHEN DOBBS CAME OUT IT WAS
UNCLEAR HOW DEMOCRATS WOULD
MESSAGE AROUND IT BECAUSE THEY
HADN'T BEEN SUCCESSFUL AROUND
ABORTION AND A REAL TALKING
POINT FOR REPUBLICANS.
IN SO MANY WAYS IT'S WOMEN'S OWN
EXPERIENCES THAT BECOME THE
MESSAGING AND EXPERIENCES OF THE
LITTLE GIRL IN OHIO RAPED AND
HAD TO GO TO INDIANA SO I THINK
IT'S A MUCH MORE FAVORABLE
ENVIRONMENT BECAUSE OF THE DOBBS
DECISION AND DEMOCRATS HAVE
FIGURED OUT HOW TO MESSAGE
AROUND IT.
WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED IN KANSAS
AND SAW WHAT HAPPENED IN THAT
NEW YORK SPECIAL ELECTION RACE,
THE IDEA THAT ABORTION RIGHTS
WERE ABOUT FREEDOM.
THAT KIND OF MESSAGE SEEMS TO BE
RESONATING WITH THE KIND OF
INDEPENDENT SWING VOTE THAT'S
ARE REALLY GOING TO BE DESIZEIVE
IN THESE CONTESTS.
>> ANA, WE'VE SEEN SOME
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES BEFORE THE
DOBBS DECISION WERE TALKING
ABOUT HOW THEY WERE 100%
PRO-LIFE, NO EXCEPTIONS EXCEPT
FOR MAYBE THE LIFE OF THE
MOTHER, ET CETERA, ET CETERA.
WE'VE SEEN THEM TRY TO ETCH A
SKETCH THEIR POSITION ON THIS,
BLAKE MASTERS, FOR EXAMPLE, IN
ARIZONA, REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE
THERE IS NOW ACTING AS THOUGH HE
HAS A MODERATE ABORTION
POSITION.
DO YOU THINK THESE ARE EXAMPLES
OF PEOPLE MODERATING THEIR
VIEWS, OR ARE THEY LYING TO
VOTERS?
>> I THINK THEY'RE LYING TO
VOTERS BECAUSE THEY WERE EITHER
LYING IN THE PRIMARY OR THEY'RE
LYING NOW.
EITHER WAY, THEY'RE LYING.
AND, LOOK, I THINK WHAT'S
HAPPENED IS MANY REPUBLICANS
UNDERESTIMATED THE CONSEQUENCES
OF THIS DECISION.
FOR SO LONG IT WAS ABOUT
CATCHING THE BUS, RIGHT?
AND NOW THAT THE BUS HAS BEEN
CAUGHT, THEY'VE GOT TO LIVE WITH
THE CONSEQUENCES AND EVERY DAY,
EVERY DAY, WE AS WOMEN ARE
READING HORRIFIC STORIES, THE
10-YEAR-OLD GIRL, THE WOMAN IN
TEXAS HAVING TO DELIVER A CHILD
WITHOUT A SKULL.
THE WOMAN WHO CAN'T GET A DNC
AFTER A MISCARRIAGE AND THAT
THREATENS HER LIFE.
EVERY DAY WE ARE SEEING WHAT THE
HORRIFIC CONSEQUENCES TO WOMEN'S
HEALTH TO FAMILIES ARE FROM THIS
DECISION, AND IT'S NOT GOING
AWAY.
IT'S NOT GOING AWAY, BECAUSE
THESE STORIES AREN'T GOING AWAY,
AND I THINK -- I THINK SENATE
REPUBLICANS AND REPUBLICANS
RUNNING ANYWHERE ARE HAVING TO
DEAL WITH THESE CONSEQUENCES OF
CATCHING THAT BUS.
>> I ALSO WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
FORMER U.S. ATTORNEY FOR THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK,
JEFFREY BERMAN.
HE HAS A NEW BOOK OUT AND DOING
INTERVIEWS ABOUT IT.
HE MAKES A SHOCKING ALLEGATION
IN HIS NEW BOOK.
HE'S A REPUBLICAN ABOUT THE
TRUMP JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
PRESSURING HIS OFFICE, THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK TO
GO AFTER TRUMP'S PERCEIVED
POLITICAL ENEMIES INCLUDING
FORMER OBAMA SECRETARY OF STATE
JOHN KERRY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP ATTACKS JOHN
KERRY IN TWO TWEETS SAYING THAT
KERRY ENGAGED IN POSSIBLE
ILLEGAL CONVERSATIONS WITH
IRANIAN OFFICIALS REGARDING THE
IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL.
THE VERY NEXT DAY, THE TRUMP
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT REFERS THE
JOHN KERRY CRIMINAL CASE TO THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK.
TWO TWEETS BY THE PRESIDENT AND
THE JOHN KERRY CRIMINAL CASE
BECOMES A PRIORITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
AND THE STATUTE THEY WANTED US
TO USE WAS ENACTED IN 1799 AND
HAD NEVER BEEN SUCCESSFULLY
PROSECUTED.
>> WE HEAR A LOT FROM LIKE THE
STEVE BANNONS OF THE WORLD ABOUT
HOW THIS IS -- YOU KNOW, HE'S
BEING PERSECUTED FOR POLITICAL
REASONS BUT THIS IS ACTUALLY AN
EXAMPLE BECAUSE YOU HAVE A
REPUBLICAN AT U.S. ATTORNEY
SAYING THIS HAPPENED OF TRYING
TO USE THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
FOR POLITICAL REASONS.
>> YEAH, I WANT TO HEAR THE
RESPONSE FROM THE PEOPLE THAT HE
ALLEGES, YOU KNOW, DID THIS
PRESSURING IN HIS BOOK, BUT, YOU
KNOW, LOOK, I ALSO THINK JOE
BIDEN HAS COMMENTED ON CERTAIN
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ISSUES
EVEN WHEN HE CLAIMED HE WAS
GOING TO BE TOTALLY INDEPENDENT
SO I DON'T KNOW THAT IF IT'S
UNIQUE --
>> THIS IS A CALL TO PROSECUTE
PEOPLE.
>> HE TWEETED OUT HIS VIEWS
ABOUT AN ISSUE.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, AFTER THE
BORDER SECURITY -- BORDER PATROL
GUYS GOT ACCUSED OF WHIPPING THE
IMMIGRANTS JOE BIDEN WENT TO THE
PODIUM WITH NO EVIDENCE
WHATSOEVER AND SAID THEY'LL PAY.
WHEN HE WANTS TO GET INVOLVED IN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE MATTERS, HE
DOES.
>> YOU DON'T SEE A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SOMEBODY COMMENTING AND
I AGREE WITH YOU THAT IT'S
INAPPROPRIATE FOR A PRESIDENT OR
VICE PRESIDENT TO COMMENT ON A
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT MATTER, A
COMMENT VERSUS A COMMENT AND
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS
REFERRING A CRIMINAL CASE TO A
SPECIFIC U.S. ATTORNEY.
>> YEAH, I WANT TO HEAR MORE
ABOUT IT.
LOOK, I'M NOT HERE TO DEFEND IT
BUT HERE TO TELL YOU HARDLY THE
FIRST PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES TO WEIGH IN ON CRIMINAL
MATTERS.
>> ANA?
>> WELL, TWO THINGS, LOOK, FIRST
OF ALL, LET'S THINK ABOUT THINGS
LIKE THE IRS AUDIT, RIGHT, OF
COMEY AND McCABE.
HOW INCREDIBLY CO-INCIDENTAL
THAT TWO OF DONALD TRUMP'S
ENEMIES, POLITICAL ENEMIES GOT
AUDITED AT THE SAME TIME.
THE EXPERTS HAVE SAID HOW RARE
THAT WAS.
IT WAS NO COINCIDENCE BUT THE
SECOND THING THAT JUST DRIVES ME
CRAZY AND IRKS ME SO MUCH ARE
ALL OF THESE COMPLICIT COWARDLY
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION, WERE PART OF
THIS PROBLEM AND KEPT QUIET FOR
ALL THIS TIME AND NOW HAVE THE
GALL TO WRITE BOOKS AND TRY TO
MONETIZE ON WHAT THEY KEPT QUIET
ABOUT WHEN THEY WERE PART OF THE
PROBLEM.
SO I HOPE THAT NOBODY WRITES
THESE BOOKS -- BUYS THESE BOOKS
FROM PEOPLE LIKE B